father what was in california just a
couple of days ago what'd you think
celebrating george palaio's wedding in
daniela which was fantastic had a great
time great but while i was there we went
to uh uh crustaceans restaurant nice
yeah so we go to crustaceans and now we
walk in and the hostess says uh
says uh uh sir if you want to eat over
here we need your vaccination card i
said you know i don't like to carry my
passport with me so they said well you
can't eat inside you know if you don't
have your passport you got to eat
outside so it's okay we'll eat outside
so we sit outside and we eat crustaceans
that said food is good you own you know
order their garlic noodles whatever they
got
so 10 minutes later i have to use the
restroom so i pulled the waiter i said
listen i got a question for you what's
that i said since i don't have my
vaccination card and i can't use the
restroom outside do i just pee on the
sidewalk what do i do he says no no sir
please don't do that you can use the
restroom i said so what do you mean i
can't go inside what are the criterias
the guy finally says honestly sir we're
just trying to figure this thing out we
have no clue what to do we just don't
want to get fined i said listen i
respect i'm just giving you a hard time
plus they have plenty of people peeing
on the sidewalk outside right you would
look like one of 600 000 people that are
currently
every day you can set up your tent
afterwards
republicans call them the homeless the
democrats call them voters but anyway
they're all they're out in the sidewalk
getting it done he said hey would you
just call them homeless democrats call
them voters exactly right hey what'd you
think what was your takeaway didn't you
love wearing a mask everywhere well i i
to tell you a few things number one we
stayed at the uh uh the four seasons
beverly hills right across from rodeo
and they were pretty chill about the
mass nobody was i put it on because i
never put it on so i'm just testing to
see if someone's gonna come and be a
mass cop no one bothered me at all okay
no one bothered me i ran into pj tucker
i said pj let me tell you something here
it says i just found out you got traded
away from the bucks i said i don't think
the bucks can win without you i can't
believe they traded you to miami he was
cracking up anyways but no one bothered
you with the mask
uh we went out and uh you know we went
to different places nobody was bothering
us with the mask a lot so it was pretty
chill and i didn't see as many homeless
people as i did six months ago eight
months ago they're cleaning it up a
little bit i think they're maybe because
we were in beverly hills after time so
you're not going to see a lot of homes
plus the super bowl is coming in a
couple months they've got to start
cleaning they've got it
yeah so good glad you had fun yeah we
did so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]